I like the second one that one's dope I
like the 8 way too bad that's what I
will yeah I don't know why we don't see
more of the 8 way d-pad your people not
like that way so that's what Peter and
Richard claimed what the 8 way ad pads
are the best well they said the Sega
Saturn d-pad they think oh yeah I think
that a lot of people are asking for Sega
Saturn controllers for PC because it's
better for fighting games not just like
it has like the six buttons so if you
play five button fighter or six month
later like that's readily available but
also like the d-pad is dope on I know
the Sega Saturn has a lot of fighting
games I never had one as a kid but I did
recently play Darkstalkers revenge and
it did feel pretty good so yeah for me
personally the best d-pad it's probably
the Super Nintendo it's just got that
like classic feel like it it's got just
enough click to it where you feel like
you know what you're doing yeah but it's
soft it's the d-pad that everyone tries
to emulate no it is yeah it feels stiff
but I think that like it'll recognize
subtle inputs like it's not gonna you
don't like to press it down like Hello
yeah definitely Nintendo have a like a
copyright oh yes they have a pound that
so that's why stuff like the ps4
controller is separated and Xbox one is
um will not talk about that okay okay
just speak for one second about the
switch d-pad because it or the pro
controller keypad because it is not good
no it's not like how does that happen
when you have a pen on the best d-pad in
the world and the first run of your pro
controllers is kind of crappy I I've
never felt as comfortable with this as I
have with a Super Nintendo totally agree
like the the inputs you'll get like
accidental inputs a lot of times yeah
and that's just the pro controller I
mean we're talking about the switch icon
yeah and it's not even really a d-pad
it's kind of it's just four buttons yes
is they do it so that you can you know
do the one handed mode but when it comes
to trying to actually use those a d-pad
it you can get used to it but it just
feels really uncomfortable on your hand
after a while yeah I feel like it is
like my thumb starts hurting when I use
a d-pad well that's why we got these
right here right
yes these are the hoary joy Khan's with
a full d-pad a real deep head here d-pad
controller by Horry it's so yeah this is
kind of like Cory's response to the
issues with this like non d-pad for
games like platformers fighting games
I'd started to kind of become a popular
thing on the switch but does it actually
fix anything you think I think it's big
time yeah I mean I play a lot of blades
BlueCross that battle and I play a lot
on ps4 but I always go fight stick but
fun play on switch which I have done a
lot as I've been traveling like using
the original d-pad for the switch it's
like it works but doing quarter circles
all the time with this it's like it
starts to really mess with your thumbs
and sometimes like the inputs aren't as
precise especially if I want to do
diagonal like exclusively with it so
when I try out the Hori d-pad I mean
it's so much easier it feels soft it's
like rubbery but not not doesn't feel
like I'm sinking in to itself so and
I've played them a bunch of plays but
I'm just like pulling off quarter
circles like it's nothing like it should
be so in that regard I think that it's
it comes in clutch to be honest if
something to be said also about how it's
like the way you have to use it is like
similar to the way you would use other
controllers so I feel like I have to
like use like like a different muscle
memory to pull off a quarter circle on
this d-pad and that actually a third
like I would eventually get used to it
and then it would throw me off when I
would go to like right ps4 to play on a
different path this actually feels
pretty different even though I'm still
playing this happen this feels really
intuitive like right away yeah you just
know how to use it and it feels good it
doesn't hurt your thumb yeah it's it's
so important I think for fighting games
we don't have that many fighting games
on switch yet but when Dragonball comes
out we know how popular Dragonball
Fighters is like a lot of people are
going to be playing it on switch totally
and I think the switch has like this
great potential for fighting games
because it's like portable and you could
just you know pull out you start to be
like I'll just hop into training mode
for like a couple minutes so I don't go
throw hands with bent I just walk over
there with my switch and then it's like
oh boom we're connected now let's fight
and that's great but you need like a
really good controller to make that
happen
yeah you can get yourself like a
you know proper like stick with a yes
are really okay it defeats the point I
had taken a fight stick on the plane so
the idea of hey we're gonna make a
specific joke on that can appeal to
somebody who wants to get into fighting
games on this which makes a lot of sense
to me yeah but I know Joey you're you're
very precise about your platformers yeah
you love Celeste a little cuphead yeah
it was on switch I would die you would
get 200% in that as well
but I know that when you're talking
about playing Celeste on switch you were
having trouble with inputs on the pro
pro controller was a problem so real
quick this is I would say the perfect
controller for Celeste oh not this and
the reason why is because when your
plane slows you're only using you're
using all eight directions at one point
but only one direction at a time so if I
want to go up forward I would just hold
these two buns and I would for there's
there's basically no no chance that
we'll get any other input other than
those there's like no guesswork there's
no guesswork whereas with the pro
controller d-pad if you move it even the
slightest bit towards ya towards four
you're only gonna get forward and I feel
like that could be the problem with this
one I haven't tested it enough but I
played enough on this to know that this
is like my preferred way of plants less
or like any platformer really it Celeste
is is ultra precise in your movement so
yeah I do kind of agree that I think the
traditional enjoy con makes a little
more sense yeah I'm not gonna have to do
like Corsica Ford's with with you know
the inputs in Celeste so that's sure you
know it's not really an issue I guess
but but a platformer where you don't
have to be quite as precise like dead
cells
I actually I found the the Hori pad more
comfortable just because your I know
that game is like really demanding and
you're constantly you know like dodge
rolling and moving around and I unlike
Celeste where I feel like you can kind
of more take your time with it
I found dead cells just the
comfortability of of the d-pad the dead
cells like was a huge factor for me
where again like playing with that other
one after a while my thumb would hurt
and it would just be like oh man like
I'm just this is just this doesn't feel
good it's kind of its kind of like
thinking about the difference between
precision and fluidity because
right in a fighting game you're like
constantly putting in hundreds of inputs
and I like per match and so if if I'm
able to flow through like different
inputs on the d-pad and it's like okay
that's beneficial but and it seems like
in your case if you just want to do one
specific input for that that's I mean
the the default d-pad would probably
take care of I mean it's not to say that
this feels bad like it still feels good
I think it's a really good like
all-purpose solution for a d-pad like on
switch by the way have you noticed that
I'm charging it right now oh yeah I
thought I was going crazy because like I
charged it last night where I charged it
here at the office and then I went home
I didn't take it out of the case and I
just opened it up and it was dead and I
was like what is going on and so
apparently these are having some issues
with being like in sleep mode attached
to the control or attached to the
console just draining the batteries yeah
it'll turn the switches batteries like
these don't have any rumble these don't
have any wireless functionality so
they're only on when they're attached to
the console which I'm thinking is
there's something so something going on
there attached just to the console I
don't think bothers me as much because I
feel like I'm specifically using this
portability purposes if I'm having it
plugged in I'm probably using the pro
controller or something else so that
doesn't that doesn't bother me as much
but I anticipate because I guess I would
have to carry around like a third joke
on and kind of swap them alright yeah I
mean I think I read that they will be
actually fixing it when release comes
around the the battery yes so thank
goodness for the but I was I thought was
going crazy yeah I think that if there's
going to be a sort of replacement or
like what is it like in like an
all-purpose solution for someone who
wants like a traditional d-pad there's a
lot of things like the charging issue
like maybe that'll be fixed but when it
comes to the nature of the switch like
this not having wireless functionality
kind
it would work like you wouldn't want to
use if you're trying to do like the
one-handed like mode like this is
supposed to be like the face buttons I
don't think that would work yeah I don't
think cuz then yeah if you want to play
like Mario Kart with two players but you
only have one set of joy Khan's like
these like you said they're supposed to
work as the face buttons and this is a
buttons or no more but we couldn't even
like booster drift yeah not only does
this not have wireless functionality but
it doesn't these are non-functional
these what are supposed to be so Schulz
you sold your buttons it's altar boy
buttons a shoulder buttons that would
even work so I mean these are fine in
the sense that like the d-pad itself is
great but it just it's missing I think
it's missing too many features to be
like the definitive replacement for joy
cons as far as like just an alternate
thing because these are a little bit
cheaper than right the regular ones
twenty-five twenty-five bucks
opposed to I think you pay like what you
were saying about having the third joy
Khan I don't think that's too much of a
problem it would probably fit in most
cases like Jeremy travel cases so you
could just throw it in attach it when
you want to play like a fighting game
and then just switch it out switch it
out for the other ones once it's cool if
you won't play like a you know Mario
Kart or something you know it's another
weird thing just as a side note is that
when you do when you detach it like
since it's not like it isn't like
exactly fit the ecosystem perfectly so
now when I detach and I try and put it
back in it's not gonna recognize it so I
feel like resync controllers yeah I had
that issue it is because it doesn't work
wirelessly so like it immediately loses
it doesn't have that inactivity between
what what mode it's in so yes you detach
it it's a pilot restart your game so
it's a little weirdness where I would
love to see an eventual
like 2.0 version this controller that
kind of like fixes some of these odd
quirks and improvements but overall I'm
happy enough with the d-pad and I play a
lot of fighting games and this is like
we said it's cheaper than a traditional
enjoy con that I I can I can see myself
picking us up okay
I like I for the blaze blues yeah always
blue thumbs dragon ball fighters and the
dragon ball fighters I
I think I might be pop yeah I would if
they fix the battery issue yeah just you
know I keep this in your bag yeah I
probably I would wreck that I mean
considering that it's 25 bucks and then
just how much I'm into fighting games
now and when they're as they start to
come upon switch more and more it's like
okay yeah I'll definitely like have this
in my back pocket well not really the
back pocket but like I'll have it in my
switch case in case I do want to play
fighters with someone and I don't want
to use the traditional ones oh yeah I
think it's it's a convenient add-on I
would say but not a full replacement I'd
say sure we're gonna make a Saturn
Patrol really got it yeah yeah yeah so
this thing's still it's it's it's it's
not as clicky as this Super Nintendo
controller I still prefer the Super
Nintendo click you know this is where
it's at man
it's soft I need a I need a little click
that's just enough I feel responsible
here I like there's lots of clicks in
this welcome to grief hoppers the show
where we prepare death into every game
[Music]
you die in a game you move on to the
next oh my god dude you had no he'll
join us live every Thursday 2:00 p.m.
Pacific don't miss it
what hit me
[Music]
you